won't want to have to look at this three
and a half million dollar house open
house I walk in said how you doing good
um what can you tell me about this
property and she leaves a customer and
comes with me and spends 45 minutes
showing the home this is at a time that
it can only probably buy 700 000
property but the fact that she thought
and believed my aura my energy was a
character of somebody that could afford
to buy three and a half million dollar
house it made me believe that I'm on my
way to be able to buy a three and a half
million dollar house so today I live in
a 30 million Auto House I don't now it's
a different story but during that time
so if somebody that's driving the Uber
car right now you got to create the
other kind of Paradigm shifts for you
wow you got to go to a completely
different environment to get yourself to
say why not me why not my family why
can't I do something about